et un bonjour et bienvenue sur des lots
tv l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs reprise soit septembre avec
évidemment le grand maître international
bourlanges bonjour et loi bonjour
stéphane bonjour à tous donc bienvenu
pour la reprise c'est la grande rentrée
septembre 2006 lors des modèles c'est
une longue histoire alors peut-être en
reparler un petit peu avant de 2 t de
revenir on va suivre l'actualité dans
cette émission c'est évident mais
peut-être revenir aussi sur l'histoire
de diagonale rendez vous assistez quoi
et pourquoi ça s'est arrêté pour le
salon prend alors diagonale c'est l
actualité internationale des échecs qui
a commencé en 99 avec canal web donc
notre cette belle société qui faisait de
la vidéo à la demande sur internet
précurseur donc en 99 à l'époque c'était
pas du tout enfin la technologie n'était
pas encore présente la bande passante
marchait pas très bien la vidéo sur
internet était un pari risqué qui s'est
avérée d'ailleurs très risqué puisque
canal web n'a pas était peut-être trop
en avance sur son temps en tout cas la
boîte n'a pas réussi à résister aux
vidéos gratuites c'est à dire que tout
était gratuit
donc il ya des problèmes la boîte a
fermé mais maintenant ça reprend n'a pas
aussi réussi peut-être un peu comme
d'autres sociétés à faire son entrée en
bourse avant que avant que le marché
sera l'intrigué c'est une autre
possibilité mais ça s'est arrêté
et maintenant aujourd'hui et bien ça
reprend
tranquillement tranquillement tout à
fait vrai 38 tranquillement à noter que
c'était quand même une production
indépendante qui était diffusée sur
canal web évidemment et qui maintenant
vont reprendre sa route en fait
indépendamment d'un diffuseur puisqu'on
est maintenant diffusée sur internet et
ce qui nous permet d'avoir une
indépendance totale et on va parler donc
maintenant de cette actualité de la
rentrée au tombe bien puisqu'on est à la
rentrée 2006 et de quoi on part à la
rentrée 2006 essentiellement eh bien on
parle systématiquement du championnat de
france d'échecs échappé à trois échecs
qui est le tournoi donc français qui
éclipse tous les autres au mois d'août
puisque il n'y a pas d'organisation qui
sont autorisés en dehors de sur quatre
ans on a autorisé par la fédération
s'est alors c'est le plus grand
événement franco français on va dire
maintenant il ya d'autres reviennent en
france sont très grands on a cité
évidemment le corsica circuit qui était
le plus grand événement français est
l'un des plus grands du mans tout
simplement et d'autres événements aussi
il ya des grands prix évident que soit
organisée à bordeaux où alex mais aussi
cappelle-la-grande il ya aussi le
championnat de paris qui est un très
grand on peut également parler du top 16
15 le champion de france par équipe qui
accueille régulièrement les meilleurs
joueurs du monde
donc ses équipes notamment le nao chess
club noches club qui probablement où va
s'arrêter et qui cassent sous sa forme
sous sa forme actuelle
donc elle est très belle équipe des très
bons joueurs donc ça fait partie aussi
des grandes compétitions françaises
évidemment le championnat de france qui
a la particularité non seulement d'être
un tournoi il ya énormément de joueurs
qui viennent
c'est de l'ordre de 5 600 700 voire
jusqu'à 1200 joueurs pour un championnat
de france qui s'est déroulé à marseille
qui est un record mais c'est aussi pour
les nationales donc ce qui a plusieurs
tournants d'un championnat de france il
y en a pour tous les niveaux du débutant
ou confirmé
et maintenant il ya deux nationaux
africains nationale a pour les plus
forts grand maître et le nacional b qui
est pour la réserve et non au grand
maître target n'y avait pas grand maître
en france et maintenant on est obligé de
faire deux oui effectivement il ya le
nombre de joueurs c'est le nombre de
grands maîtres s'est multiplié donc il
ya de plus en plus de joueurs on entre
là l'élite aussi française est de plus
en plus forte puisque maintenant avec
lautier bacrot freyssinet donc quatre
chefs qui est devenu français maxime
vachier lagrave qui pointe vers les 2600
plus on aime très très belle enfin on a
une tête de championnat qui est
extrêmement forte
donc effectivement on a fait en
nationale b c'est une c'était un essai
et 1 je pense je sais pas si ce chat ce
national d être réédité met donc le
national baissé pour les joueurs de 13 à
24 lors rien que mercredi en suivant
voilà il met talent pour se qualifie
pour chaplin trader évidemment il ya
toujours la condition de vélo si on est
très fort on est loin d'être qualifié
peut-être les si peu d'eau les six
premiers loups doivent être
automatiquement qualifiés je suppose
alors il ya des où il ya des critères
par exemple on prend les cinq derniers
champions de france
les deux derniers vice champion de
france les 5 derniers des champions de
france de l'année précédente
il ya donc il ya des critères comme ça
et ensuite c'est par ordre de liste et
l'eau il ya aussi le national
qualifie voilà ocana 2 je crois qu'ils
montent c'est certain le national a
façon certaine
ils sont sûrs d'être qualifiés alors on
voit une baisse de fréquentation du
championnat de france légère baisse
puisque la dui un peu moins de 800
joueurs je crois à besançon cette année
l'explication probablement et du refus
du public de rester deux semaines parce
que c'est très long le tournoi ça dure
11 rondes plus un jour de repos arrive
un jour avant partie d'un jour après ses
très longs donc je pense que le public
le joueur moyen le joueur de club moyen
l'amateur des chèques a envie d'un temps
des plus courants ou de cadences plus
rapide éventuellement un tournoi qui
durerait plus tôt huit ou neuf jours
voire 10 mais pas deux semaines deux
semaines c'est ça peut justifier
effectivement la baisse de fréquentation
s'échapper à trans
alors il ya peut-être peut-être
plusieurs paramètres c'est difficile
d'expliquer toujours peut-être une
baisse alors il ya ça mais il ya
peut-être aussi une multiplicité des
tournois la plus en vue du tournoi il ya
énormément de tournage l'été à venir ils
sont presque même souvent concurrentes
et peut-être aussi des tanks
quand il ya une grande offre peut-être
les gens vont plus dans des tournois
dans les lieux où ils veulent aller et
puis du coup vous par chaplin de france
parce qu'on peut pas non plus passer
deux mois à jouer aux échecs c'est exact
effectivement on peut être tenté par les
tornades la côte d'azur il ya nice
cannes et avait beau tournoi comme ça -
aquitaine d'un très bon teint qui était
très beau temps dans l'aquitaine sans
doute le temps dont il ya aussi le pic
danic maintenant quénéhen pyrénées je
crois qu'il ya aussi à condom quelqu'un
qui te fait à côté
rappelons que stéphane de bordeaux
aquitaine pub effectivement un peu plus
ça fait jamais de mal
mais effectivement dans le champion de
france garde quand même un statut festif
c'est là où tout le monde se retrouve
c'est là où il ya le plus de joueurs
donc normalement c'est le tournoi qui
attire les accessoires d'échec surtout
la nouvelle star en fait donc on peut
quand même voir si les stars avec une
projection des partis avec des
commentaires c'est ça et on peut côtoyer
les plus grandes stars françaises qui
sont mes lautier qui sont freyssinet qui
sont quatre chefs maintenant qu'ils sont
igor nataf aussi par exemple il y avait
encore écrit à gbagbo il n'ya pas
longtemps mais internet et il est facile
d'accès art et essai qu'il ait passé un
cap plus plus plus international qui
fait qu'il a plutôt envie de tourner
encore plus fort disons qu etienne
bacrot a gagné cinq fois de suite quand
même ce qui est encore à comprendre oui
qui les nourrit de freiner un peu
cependant qu'ils deviennent assez
risquées d'ailleurs au niveau des points
elo parce que mine de rien les
adversaires se défendent sont tous très
très bon c'est très dur de gagner des
parties c'est un certain et etienne
bacrot qui a gagné cinq fois de suite
sony qui préfère jouer les super tournoi
que le championnat de france mais bon
nul doute qu'il va revenir parce qu'en
fait là il n'a pas joué probable pas
forcément parce que ils pensaient que
l'otan n'était pas pour lui mais
simplement parce qu'il avait son match
contre cannes ce qui a préparé
qu'est-ce qui joue un match des
candidats contre kenzy en septembre donc
une cro match donc grosse préparation
obligatoire mais j'étais candidat ça
reprend donc c'est très important pour
etienne bacrot de bien réussir ce truc
là donc il a effectivement pas échappé à
la france qui est quand même un tournoi
fatiguant tout à fait alors il ya aussi
une autre
peut-être un autre pouvoir à noter pour
cette année par exemple qui n'ont qu'à
le tournoi de cession qui est le tour
notre qualif prince une halle b
maintenant et qui a été je crois qu'il y
avait une demi surprise on dirait c'est
je crois c'est romain edouard qui a
terminé deuxième et qui lui est un grand
espoir aussi français il est très jeune
romain edouard la première fois que j'ai
vu ce joueur c'était à port barcarès en
finale du top 16 donc d'années près
l'année passée il est fait forte
impression puisqu'en fait il joue très
très bien il était mou n'est pas très
grand enfin ils l'étaient pas ils
avaient l'air de rien il est très jeune
et très très jeune mais il joue déjà
très bien ces partis sont très
impressionnantes
donc effectivement c'est une demi
surprise en fait c'est même pas une
surprise c'est à dire que pour moi il
était probablement favorise l'accession
alors ça c'était pour le tourment
accession maintenant évidemment plein
feux sur nationale alors nationale
grande nouveauté cette année c'est la
présence de la 19,4 chef depuis très
longtemps résidents français au club de
cannes c'est un merlot vasic qu'il a
fait venir à calais il a joué très
souvent en france il avait jeté le grand
tournoi d'enghien par exemple et il
avait joué aussi le grand prix de
bordeaux en l'an 2000 il avait fait une
belle prestation aussi et il a joué de
tout un tas de tournoi en france il est
surnommé mister minit d'un des meilleurs
joueurs du monde en bits en partie
rapide donc extrêmement rapide beau
gosse aussi très très dandy on l'appelle
d'indy du jeu d'échecs
oui effectivement il a un beau style à
l'impôt style et vladislav catch est
donc qui est naturalisé cette année
depuis depuis je crois le mois d'avril
oui donc c est très très récent et qui
un petit peu comme je crois à la fée
anatolie valserres c'est à dire l'année
où ils deviennent naturalisé davet enfin
oui mais naturalisé vous deviez français
et bien il joue nationale et le gagne
oui oui alors vladislav tkachiev a
toujours été amoureux de la france comme
beaucoup de russes comme beaucoup de
joueurs russes
il s'est impliqué beaucoup dans le
développement des chaînes françaises
puisqu'il a été habité à cannes il a
donné des cours tout un tas de gens de
joueurs y parle français couramment donc
tout naturellement il a été naturalisé
français je vois pas ce qui aurait pu se
passer autres il arrive au national et
il fait très très bon tournoi très belle
performance + 4 assez facile les partis
qui sont très très propre il a un très
très beau style effectivement une
particularité au niveau des blitz
stéphane c'est qu'il était très rapide
et christian bauer me disais ce qui est
très dur et vladislav tkachiev c'est que
il joue les mêmes coûts impliquant
partie longue
sauf qu'il déjoue tout de suite on va
passer sur le classement français tout
de suite comment pouvoir voir ici je
sais pas si on peut le voir exactement
mais en tout cas il a disposé sur
internet assure le site de la fidh
ici on la fuit des points comme est
finie level.com et on voit en premier
donc etienne bacrot en deuxième jouaient
le joël lautier toujours saignant donc
vladislav tkachiev qui prend la
troisième place et qui souffle alors
africiné la troisième place il était 4e
l'an dernier parce que l'arrière kristin
bauer et il est toujours 4e danse parce
qu'il est derrière villa du quartier
puisque bauer lui a perdu beaucoup de
points l'an dernier oui
christian bobin ont fait une très très
mauvaise série là on sait pas ce qui lui
arrive il a une sorte de panne d'idées
je sais pas ce qui se passe au nul doute
qu'il va revenir à son meilleur niveau
mais là il est passé en dessous dès 2006
qui est quand même inattendu parce que
c'est un très très bon joueur qui joue à
priori plutôt à 2632 1140 que 2600 alors
vous pouvez retrouver ce classement
des lumières joueurs français sur le
site fi des points comme défi des points
comme et vous allez denrées deans et
puis là vous avez soit les meilleurs
joueurs du monde soit les meilleurs
joueurs français en l'occurrence ici
avec donc cette belle troisième place
glace café café alors ce championnat de
france eloi s'est jouée entre laurent
frayssinet et 24 cattier une
course-poursuite on peut dire loin de
signes a très vite pris les devants et
suivi quasiment tous tournois parmi
elles quatre chefs qui leur montrent
dans la dernière ronde je crois c'est de
l'avant dernière journée avant les
rondes où il bat fabien les business qui
une bonne partie alors ce qu'il faut
voir c'est que laurent frayssinet une
fois de plus souffert de son défaut
principal c'est-à-dire qui commence très
fort et ensuite il a ce syndrome
il arrive plus à gagner il s'endort il
s'endort un peu sur son résultat et donc
comme souvent avec laurent frayssinet la
fin de tournoi est mauvaise alors ici
elle n'a pas été catastrophique
puisqu'il a perdu deux parties il a
commencé avec +4 dans les six premières
parties c'est-à-dire qu'il a commencé
par 5 sur 6 et ensuite il a fini avec
eux des nuls alors voyons ce tableau si
on peut nous mettre en incruste sur ce
tableau
voilà c'est à dire en voit très bien la
disquette chef premiers à égalité en
fait avec laurent frayssinet au bout des
doigts avec cette déroute 5 points sur
et ma foi un parcours très très
semblable pour les deux joueurs avec une
meilleure performance pour laurent
frayssinet mais qui est du tout
simplement au fait ça ne seront pas
fermées que l'on a fasciné un classement
un peu inférieur à celui de vlad dans ce
qui fait que c'est normal fait de 1700 à
peu près d'autres performances même
exactement où laurent frayssinet ce qui
est énorme parce que ça le place dans
l'est
s'il faisait toujours neuf cas comme ça
sur le placerait dans les 15 ou 20
millions du monde
oui et l'a10 l'a4 chef est à peu près la
même fait la même chose à 2698 donc de
performance donc équivalent à deux
points près ils ont tous les deux fait
un parcours très solide puisqu'ils ont
pas perdu deux parties quatre victoires
et 7 nuls chacun donc effectivement bon
parcours en en général national se gagne
effectivement à + 4 voire plus cinq ans
et etienne bacrot des tombes à croire
qu'ils aient des scores assez fleuve et
on peut mentionner qu'à la surprise de
ce championnat l'autre la véritable
surprise c'est robert fontaine
oui donc plus grosse surprise c'est la
troisième place de robert fontaine
effectivement qui fait une performance
remarquable 2670 selo 74 exactement sur
aux partys france est parti assez
impressionnant une seule défaite face à
bressols à andré pardon ce qu'il pense
et c'est l'autre gros call of ancien
candidat au titre mondial puisqu'il
était finaliste face à kharkov les
années 90 donc très très beau résultat
robert fontaine qu'on voyait pas trop
ces temps-ci ces derniers temps et qu'il
a fait une super super il a toujours
bien réussi le championnat de france
robert fontaine là il était qualifié
avec 2518 il était qualifié de justesse
parce qu'il avait terminé cinquième de
l'année précédente
sinon ils n'étaient pas forcément
c'était un le plus petit et l'eau en
dehors des qualifiés de l'accession de
l'année passée donc robert fontaine qui
était chaud motivé plutôt en forme en il
avait il avait l'air resplendissant on
va dire le bronze et sportif
donc ça joue quand même ça joue parce
que le temps est long le tournoi
difficile donc physiquement je pense
qu'il a bien tenu le coup
donc il a très bien joué il n'a pas
réussi à gagner la dernière ronde contre
vincent colin avec les pièces blanches
sinon il rejoint les matchs des partages
avec à vladislav tkachiev les
impressionner tout à fait dit alors
ensuite on voit une belle performance
aussi de
vachier lagrave notre notre jeu de
maxime maintenant membre de l'équipe de
france qui fait une belle perf pour à
son niveau à peu près un policier ça
c'était en dessous ils ont quand même un
point d'écart avec robert fontaine ils
ont six points donc six points c'est
moins bien c'est à dire que robert
fontaine avait 7 il ya personne qui a
six et demi donc maxime fait une
performance à 2600 ce qui est de son
niveau il réussit toujours bien de
champion de france mais là il n'a pas
fait un tournoi exceptionnel
je voudrais juste qu'on a juste un petit
message à la régie qui nous entend juste
qu'on nous signale sur une feuille de
papier le temps passé depuis début
d'émission voilà une fois à simplement
de qu'on puisse suivre l'évolution de
cette émission puisqu'on n'est pas
encore super au poids notamment au
niveau du temps alors on va maintenant
peut-être passé mais au coeur du sujet
de cette émission parce qu'évidemment
diagonale sans analyse ça peut pas ça
peut pas exister il faut analyser une
partie évidemment qu'est ce qu'on a
choisi c'est une partie de l'esclave
cacher alors les le 24e rang fasciné ont
fini à égalité
ce championnat est en fait là le
départage s'est fait en partie rapide
oui parce qu'on ne peut pas décerner un
titre de champion de france à égalité de
points ils ont fait tous les deux sets
et demi contre les mêmes adversaires se
serait donc injuste d'utiliser un
quelconque système de départage donc la
logique veut des parties semi-rapides
d'accord donc on a passé alors tout de
suite avant de passer à l'analyse
on va voir quand même une petite vidéo
justement comme ça s'est décidé entre
laurent frayssinet le catch est bien on
a choisi de vous montrer des images de
grand prix de bordeaux 2 lille ou
ladislav quatre chefs avait battu
laurent frayssinet dans le match de
départage pour la troisième place et on
va voir ces images si dès que la régie
voudra les lancers un très beau moment à
l'époque filmé sur des monnaies
mais blanc au centre est très importante
dans ce type de chemins où les
possibilités d'attaqués directes sont
sont moins possible parce que les rois
sont là en face de l'autre tout
simplement voilà si le roi blanc a été à
gauche on les blancs pourraient pousser
ses pions devant le roi mais
actuellement comme le roi est là si on
pousse les pions pour attaquer le roi
noir en même temps on affaiblit le roi
blanc donc laurent fasciné toujours
fidèle à lui-même il ne change jamais
ils ne changent jamais les coups qu'il
prépare parce que j'ai fait quelques
blitz récemment avec lui des parties
rapides et il m'a joué exactement la
même chose donc c'est une preuve de
confiance c'est une preuve de confiance
on avait parlé hier donc on reconnaît là
à un trait psychologique chez le jeune
joueur qui qui qui perdure quoi qui
continuent de absolument il a confiance
en lui la confiance dans ses ouvertures
dans son répertoire et c'est pas une
défaite de temps à autres qui va le
faire changer ses opinions sur les
ouvertures
voilà donc de belles images
ouvrant fasciné il a essayé de cacher
c'était à s'affronter dans ce grand prix
de bordeaux donc c'était un peu une île
s'étaient préparés finalement faurecia
pilote france 2006 six ans après se sont
retrouvés mais là ils ont été peut-être
à distance un homme dans ce championnat
et à la fin c'est encore mieux retrouver
pour veiller partage oulad encore une
fois montre de sa supériorité en partie
rapide car il est très très fort en
partie rapide
à noter quand même que laurent
frayssinet a été
vice-champion d'europe de beats qui est
donc des parties de cinq minutes devant
vladislav tkachiev laurent frayssinet
est très très fort en partie rapide il
est vraiment très fort parce qu'il est
une préparation les ouvertures
exceptionnelles
il est trahi beaucoup justement avec
yvan sokolov perdre avec le joueur
batave
il a bien une très très bonne
préparation avec les noirs sur des
quatre il est parfait sur quatre il
s'est mis à jouer espagnol il ya un
répertoire très solide maintenant et
avec les blancs il va chercher les
points en jouant son jeu quatre
habituels donc laurent frayssinet très
bon dans les ouvertures très rapide il
est toujours quelques très vite il est
très bon techniquement manque peut-être
un peu de créativité dans certains types
de position mais sinon c'est un joueur
tout à fait exceptionnelle parfaitement
adapté aux parties rapides tkatchev
également et qui sans l'avoir un jeu
laurent fascination qui fait beaucoup
d'efforts alors assez intuitive son jeu
finalement fait n'avait finalement
travail derrière
mais c'est quand même assez naturel ça
semble naturel ou écoute chacun sont
chacun son avis alors on va voir une
partie exceptionnelle de vladislav
tkachiev dans ce championnat de france
2006 face à maxime vachier lagrave une
belle partie presque une miniature on
peut dire oui mais une partie très
rapide un peu moins de 25 ou ladislav
quel chef qui a été acquis à très bien
jouer cette partie on va voir mais c'est
ce qui est intéressant dans cette partie
stéphane c'est qu'elle elle est
parfaitement fidèle au style de
vladislav tkachiev c'est à dire qu'il
fait exactement comme d'habitude y
placent bien ces pièces il prend
l'initiative
ils dominent l'échiquier y met tous au
centre il prend tout quand toutes les
cases et au final une petite combinaison
pour conclure alors on va avancer deux
parties donc face à un maxi de la
chiraquie cas rien aussi la grande
révélation logiciels français sont en
plein boom mais on parle de fictivement
il ya une des petites affections
championnat de france mais c'est d'abord
qu'une petite désaffection
on a quand même une fédération qui a
maintenant plus de 52 ou 53 me licencier
alors qu'il y avait un lien adéquat y
avait dix mille
il ya quand même maintenant une pléthore
de grands maîtres en france et des stars
qui qui éclosent bon évidemment y ait
une macro dont on espère encore
d'excellents résultats on en a plus y en
a reparlé 9,9 fois mais qui a déjà
réussi de grands résultats
on a joué nos pieds ça fait maintenant
longtemps que je joue elle est sur le
devant de la scène
on a évidemment laurent frayssinet on a
tous si hambourg qui est arrivé après
derrière l'étonnant et maxime vachier
lagrave qui quand même et les revend les
doigts et armés noir mais il ya aussi
jeune moussa par exemple aussi
exactement prometteur il est chez les
filles si on peut on peut placer chez
les filles il ya quand même une grande
progression
on a un maître international formé en
france parce qu'évidemment égaleme ramé
qui n'est pas française d'origine
marie sebag et marie ses bas de former
en france maître international et puis
derrière il ya de jeunes joueuses qui
tout de mieux en mieux pauline guichard
par exemple une jeune joueuse aussi
qu'il ya deux mille trois cents lots qui
a peut-être donc passé maître
international
tout ça démontre qu'il ya de plus en
plus de mettre la plus en plus d'un
grand maître en france je crois qu'en
d'inciter mais on fait partie des
meilleures nations du monde
oui exact c'est vrai que si on prend les
dix premiers du classement je crois
qu'on doit être 4e c'est à dire sur le
la moyenne des dix premiers jours on est
quatrième derrière les russes l'arménie
probablement si on fait un rapport par
rapport à la densité de population je
pense que même on les garde et peut-être
même mieux que ça on est bien on est
même très bien alors on va regarder
cette partie entre quatre chefs et
machina voilà tout de suite cette partie
est loin que tu as choisi pour cette
émission
oui donc vladislav tkachiev avait blanc
contre maxime vachier lagrave c'est la
quatrième ronde du championnat pour
l'instant vladislav qu'elle fait gagner
une partie est là ils essaient de
joue simplement cavani f3 alors il faut
voir déjà que de quatre chefs peut jouer
également eu 4 au premier bout mais il
joue principalement les ouvertures à
base d'options dame donc comme qui
l'accueille en trois c'est faire ça et
maxime joue systématiquement la défense
grubfeld des forces nouvelles qui est
une défense donc basé à base d'oeuf ou
enfle enquêteurs qu'avait dit en raid 6
et l'avancée du pion en d5 parents des
six qui serait un stand en d5 d'accord
donc tu connais bien séché mal voilées
connais très bien ces schémas là il la
joue très très bien des forces nouvelles
notons que maxime se prépare avec arnaud
charge quelqu'un le grand théoricien
français
oui des experts de la théorie en france
est relaté donc quel chef à chercher
quelque chose d'un peu d'evian pour
éviter cette grande fête dont qui
commence par qui veut dire trois
cavaliers m6 voilà donc ce rebond pour
est un sport qui normal des pièces et
maintenant elle fait ses 4 donc c'est
pas tout à fait une grande fête ici
c'est ce qu'on appelle un système anti
grünfeld maintenant sur le congé 6 et
bien poursuit par cavalli c3 et sur des
cinq comprendre qu'il va les prendre
maintenant je crois qu'il ya des
subtilités à base de damas quatre échecs
éventuellement oui on n'a pas mis le
pied en d4
donc ça change tout ça change donc c'est
ce qu'on appelle un système anti grippal
qui décide contre et finalement ce que
maxime préfère c'est ça donc là on
rentre finalement on est dans la
préparation des joueurs c'est à dire que
les joueurs à ce niveau là
se prépare face à l'adversaire
connaissent évidemment leur force
connaissent leurs faiblesses et la
vaisselle café fabule les parties de nos
clients qui réservent sur les bases de
données les joueurs qui ont énormément
de bastonner bien entendu avec des bases
de millions de parties donc toutes les
parties ndlr sont dedans et il analysé
son style et il a essayé la et de le à
la fois de le contrer c'est à dire de
lui l'empêcher de jouer si leurs 9 avril
mais aussi lui d'essayer de jouer et qui
pour lui son enfant facile à jouer
exactement donc ici il a voulu éviter
les grandes lignes de la défense
hauts-de-seine
il lui a joué ce petit système sur quoi
maxime a répondu par ces 5 et là on
retombe dans une défense anglaise
symétrique malades accord alors donc la
très logique le coup j'ai 3 pourquoi ces
logiques stéphane et bien simplement aux
échecs on rappelle les trois grands
principes d ouverture on va le rappeler
puisque c'est la rentrée prendre le
centre sortir les pièces et rauque et
rapidement non prendre le centre ici on
voit que lecavalier a été sortie vers le
centre on va mettre le fou sur la 4g 2
voilà toujours vers le centre pas pour
la grande diagonale 1,6 à 2,4 centrale
donc on va contrôler casque enfin les
contrôle pas tout à fait mais par
transparence par quatre ans avec le
cavalier aura joué le fou subtil
d'attaquer ces casses donc c'est c'est
un contrôle en deuxième main mais c'est
en général d'ailleurs les plus les plus
vicieux et ensuite on prépare le petit
rock ce qui veut dire que dans deux
coups on a sorti deux pièces pris le
contrôle du centre et ils droit à l'abri
ce qui est quand même très très
important donc voilà l'idée de cacher un
fils maxime fait pareil pour l'instant
sextant asymétrique soucy trilogie qui
nous échappe on peut pas jouer
symétrique jusqu'au bout ça ne marche
pas puisqu'on est mat avant un autre
week-end est ici alors petite astuce un
d'autres cas de chiens fils n'a pas
mille fois en jets d'eau directement
il a préféré s'imposer au centre tout de
suite en juin coût des cartes donc
évidemment ces théories un stéphane tout
ça est bien connu il ya des parties
d'inférence donc on va avancer
irène dangereux et de toute façon on
peut jouer presque tous les coups enfin
standard de développement dans cette
position là sont jouables
il n'y a pas de subtilité il
deux pièges énorme / / / ses premiers
coups en tout cas pour le moment tout va
bien si on prend des quatre est très
logique
donc on échange c'est à dire que ici les
blancs menaces et éventuellement de
prendre ces cinq ou éventuellement je
vois des cinq donc de toutes façons on
allait finir par le prendre ce pion
voulait pas le laisser là pouvait l'être
c'est pas mauvais des changes est un
pion du centre de toute façon donc ça
prend des quatre cavaliers prend des
quatre très logique alors évidemment on
est vite sans doute de reprendre avec la
dame on veut être rappelé à pour wii
pour peut-être ceux qui découvrent le
jeu d'échecs ou qui savent eux mêmes
peut jouer imaginons qu'on prenne avec
lada vont peut-être se montrer
oui et bien maintenant tout de suite les
noirs répondre et cavaliers probablement
terrien 6,6 oui c'est une possibilité il
y en a une autre stéphane mais alors
effectivement celle là est la plus
éducative mettre les camions ccist
l'autre option c'est de mettre le fond
j'ai c'est tout simple bien sûr avec
attac rayons x sur la dame mais le plus
intrigué les c6 adam et attaquer tout de
suite la dame attaqué de suite obligé de
repartir voilà mettons en d1 et on a
perdu du temps on a perdu du temps et en
attendant les noirs en sortie des pièces
maintenant c'est la pression devient
très facile à jouer pour les noirs
puisque après le g7 on peut compter les
pièces sorties propre cette sortie
contre une voile un avantage manta
simplement on prépare ce soit des cinq
mauvais coup quand même et bouffe ça y
est davantage parle de barcelone quand
ça peut lasser vie donc d'où l'intérêt
de reprendre toujours avec les pièces de
moindre valeur en fait de toute façon là
souvent nous aussi on peut choisir
enfin s'il ya danger c'est pas tout à
fait ça se passe il ya danger c'est
quand même mieux de prendre soin avec
lampions ensuite avec une pièce et après
avec une dame wintour en fait ça dépend
il s'inscrit dans un plan de jeu c'est à
dire que si on avait décidé que la dame
elle a bien un rôle important à jouer au
match 4 par exemple il y en aura plus de
la dame dans le camp ce n'est pas le cas
la dame n'a rien à faire au match 4
en tout cas pour le moment donc
effectivement qu'on préfère ne pas
perdre de temps mais c'est une question
de temps tout simplement c'est à dire
que si on prend de la dame elle se fait
attaquer tout de suite l objet de
repartir et c'est pas bon parce que en
même temps enfin bon ils sont une pièce
en attaquant la table donc ça va donc
ici et prend des quatre logis cavaliers
fou g7 normale normale on développe ses
pièces coûtent près par le petit rock
évidemment l'idée toujours évidemment
c'est de mettre le roi et 8 ici à l'abri
très vite sur le côté le rock toujours
important de rock est assez vite
quoique là c'est une pulsion type fermé
on n'est pas super précié donc lui mais
bon de toute façon c'est un compte il
faut chaud tôt ou tard notons ici que ce
qui est ce qu'il est et ce qui est très
important dans ce genre de position
c'est que les avantages long terme est
passée du côté blanc maintenant c'est à
dire que si les blancs sort toutes leurs
pièces parfaitement et bien auront un
petit avantage
tout simplement à cause du pion c-46
idées noires marquent pas jouer des cinq
pour échanger déception ils vont jouer
avec des six est donc on aura un pion
ces quatre contre un pion des six ce qui
nous donne un avantage intéressant c'est
à dire cet avant poste sur la caisse des
5 peut imaginer un trajet de cavaliers
qui viendrait se placer sur les caisses
des cinq avantages des espaces
simplement parce que l'option c4 sera
plus proche copions décide donc ici on
peut considérer que si les blancs sont
toutes leurs classes et les noirs aussi
que les nord ouest et si c'est bien sûr
un petit avantage non sur le long terme
d'accor fou j'ai deux c'est normal petit
round faty rock cavalli c3 on blinde
complètement les cas ce dessin pour les
empêche noir voilà c'est dark si les
blancs avaient croqué peut-être
peut-être si les blancs vérité il est
possible que l'ajustement maxime rentrer
dans ses schémas dont on avait parlé en
début de partie
là il peut jouer le coup des 5 il peut
jouer le coup des 5 alors qu'elle pas
approprié mais en tout cas hier là il
est possible techniquement il est
possible techniquement c'est possible de
jouer des coudes et 5 pas forcément
extraordinaire mais il faut en fait
série va falloir vérifier quoi là il
faut c'est bien on est bien dans cette
version mais je pense d'ailleurs que ça
doit marcher ça coûtait 5 mois et de
quatre chefs ne l'a pas autorisé maxime
il aurait certainement je suis donc ici
qu'avait laissé 3 je vois pas quel chef
et maintenant on arrive dans le débat
c'est à dire que même s'il ne veut pas
jouer une pression normale
ou alors si je vous dès 600 à midi il
aurait peut-être un petit désavantage
c'est ça a dû à la casse des cinq du à
l'avant un avantage l'espace côté blanc
un sujet devient actif en montrant
pourquoi des six alors évidemment un des
six toujours fait le problème pour les
noirs mais non ça va développer souffre
ou la trousse chemise on sait pas trop
où le mettre bon voilà on ne peut pas on
peut difficilement jouer b6 on va
montrer pourquoi possible voilà parce
qu'il ya un fou qui prendrait à tous
voilà ce que ce fameux foule à prendre
et la tour ce serait il immédiat
donc en fait seuls d'autres possibilités
ça serait des six mais bien en jouant
des sites en plus c'est pas facile parce
que le fou contrôlent toujours la grande
diagonale voilà
ça va pas être simple de se développer
et en plus donc cette case des 5 et
quand même fermement dans la montre et
cette case fermement même des blancs et
des 6es au resto ou passive pour contre
attaquer sur un euro au centre dans
l'autre alternative sympathique sedgwick
evans et 6 éventuellement un peu plus
conquérant on va échanger une pièce au
centre déjà changé ce qui avait signé
quatre
ensuite on va essayer de sortir nos
pièces mais ici maxime à trouver quand
même mieux dans cette position après
qu'il ait c3 il a joué l'idée remise à
la mode par igor nataf
ah le fameux jordaan le fameux y voir un
taf qui lui est très très bien préparés
aussi dans des zones arthur rimbaud
championnat de france notamment je crois
que c'est la partie d'ailleurs face à je
passais pas ça face à fontaine justement
oui nous oriente donc ce n'était pas
face à monter un peu violent a fait un
tout qu'elle avait joué une variante un
peu désuète et d'ailleurs qu'il a perdu
il ya choc entre maxime et une partie
très très spectaculaire s'est peut-être
contre main avec sacrifice de dames et
tout le tralala voilà un échec perpétuel
à la fin c'était extrêmement chaud et y
en a mais il fait toujours des parties
des parties spectaculaire c'est un très
très beau linge coquitlam une partie
avec f 5 4 5 et 5
vers la fin moi j'ai vu ça enfin quelque
chose de peu le spectacle se termine a
perdu mais ce que disait aux
commentaires d'ailleurs puisque arnaud
hauchard était aux commentaires il y
avait aussi jean baptiste est donc
excellent commentateur de man qui avait
signalé que même si la tâche hyper au
moins il fait le spectacle
voilà ça c'est fait avec moi en a pour
son argent tout à fait y en as tu as
fait un très très beau joueur
donc ici dans cette pression nataf a
trouvé une idée assez originale qu'on va
voir tout de suite le petit coup comme
ces sept îles et jouer enfin maxime il a
joué face à levon aronian comme la star
libanaise par convient que la nouvelle
rame à montréal c'est la nouvelle grande
star un choix on peut dire d'un rognant
qu'il a explosé cette saison
abba complet quasiment inconnu
complètement au début la saison dernière
ils gagnent un coup du monde totalement
inconnu stéphane non mais quasiment
inconnu de dépassement de l'amateur
l'amateur de la bâtisse il a quand même
été champion du monde chez les jeunes
filles et des matchs contre etienne bat
ans était le concurrent détiennent bakr
au moment où les deux étaient non mais
c'est évidemment un très grand joueur un
super grand maître puisqu'il aimait déjà
plus de 2650 je sais pas exactement mais
tout en début de saison c'était pas une
arme un shirokov ou un adam sous un écho
mais déjà trois pistoles et il a tout
écrasé à dire que keegan de coupe du
monde
derrière ils gagnent linares ah oui oui
il est très très fait et qu'est ce qu'il
a gagné d'autres il n'a pas gagné un
troisième je sais pas si le pagne du
chorus nom n'était pas au courant il a
dû enfin je sais pas mais le fait d'être
des résultats là aussi c'est l'homme qui
monte le baril a gagné la cp tout voilà
c'est du kenya s'était toujours c'est à
dire c'est le meilleur joueur de la
saison à rognan et donc il vers nataf a
joué sept nouveautés dont tu nous parles
ce drame ses sets face à ce fameux levon
aronian il ya quelques temps il ya
quelques temps je crois que c'est aux
olympiades
pas de pleine mer
non c'était les olympiades d'après enfin
il ya quelques années il a joué ça c'est
cette attaque le pion ces quatre mois la
première simplement l'air chaud déjà
j'aille menace mp3 c'est la défense
normal d'options alors dans ce genre de
position loin on n'a pas souvent envie
d'une des trois parce que justement il
ya le fou ici g7 est maintenant à part
transparence trois pièces il ya plus qu
en b2 pour arrêter voilà il ya plutôt de
pied 2 pour apprécier ce fou ya trois
pièces qui traînent bon mais de l'autre
côté pour l'instant on voit pas trop
comment pourrait déloger le cavalier des
quatre examens oui très bien cette
diagonale mais c'est toujours un coup où
il faut réfléchir à ne jouer que cela
dit on n'a pas d'autre moyen de défendre
ses pions parce que le ku'damm détroit
par exemple s'expose à des arrivées de
cavaliers soit en peu 5 kg 4 kg 5 qui
serait un truc standard plus le cas des
rues sainte-catherine pioncer 400 fois
plus soit à des avancées des avancées de
développement cavalia six caisses et 5
on va gagner du temps sur la date et la
dame en d3 et sur une case exposés donc
on n'a pas envie de jouer même d'être
fermés l'attend comment des champions et
biarritz plus 36 millions d'âmes b3
c'est pas terrible c'est très moyen
toujours à cause du câble équipe hormis
ans et cinq ans plus le cahier des cats
seraient entreprises ce qui veut dire
qu'on peut jouer des découvertes à des
choses comme ça donc ici b3 normal et là
c'est là que le coup dit que leur arrive
des cinq cercles fils d'options donne un
pion ici puisque la caisse des 5
stéphane comme on l'a dit avait été
plutôt bien contrôlé par quatre chefs
trois pièces mais on joue quand même ce
coup des 5 alors pourquoi en tout ça est
bien effectivement stéphane
l'explication tient en un mot c'est ce
fou g7 qui dans toutes les variantes va
se réveiller
ça c'est toujours la nouveauté du corps
nataf c'est ça ça avait été jouée avant
mais ça a été remis à la mode par
ailleurs nataf d'accord mais ça veut
dire les bonnes aronian avait joué les
trois aussi les vannes à rien
joe b3 ici on est dans la dans la partie
maintenant qu'est ce qui se passe ici
c'est une conception qui a l'air assez
douteuse pour les noirs parce que là
d'avancé 7 elle est mal passé
l'équivalent et peuvent sauter en d5 le
fou peut aller au f4 pour l'attaqué bref
la dame ans et s'était pas très bien
placé
l'option des 5 et de reprise donc tout
ça à l'air douteux mais il se trouve que
après analyse approfondie
évidemment il donne la tafna pas jouer
ça on sent bien connaître et bien les
blancs des problèmes pour prendre
avantage donc le coût principal était
calé prend des 5
je crois que c'est ce qui a été joué
dans la majeure partie des partis et la
nouveauté d'autres catcheurs qui avaient
préparé cette position là stéphane c'est
petit rock
d'accord c'est profond un nouveau thème
et qu'un coup peut jouer donc ça veut
dire que là quand j'en veux toujours
dans la préparation à la maison voilà et
ça veut dire que ça à ce niveau là sans
préparer à la maison jusqu'à jusqu'à là
jusqu au moins 12 corps 15e coup c'est
très difficile de tenir la comparaison
est de trouver des choses sur
l'échiquier on va on va c'est pas
tellement qu'on va peut-être trouver
forcément d'ailleurs les meilleurs coups
etc
il s'agit de se préparer spécifiquement
contre l'adversaire et l'embêter le plus
possible c'est pas évident en fait il
faut voir que 2k czech fait un très très
lent que ses collègues
c'est à dire qu'il arrive à prévoir les
ouvertures qui vont arriver notamment
contre leurs racines et où il est prévu
les positions qu'il a eu avec les blancs
et les noirs dans les matchs des
partages il est prévu les positions de
matin il avait déjà joué sans parti à
l'entraînement donc il arrive à sentir
ce qu'on va jouer son adversaire
donc ici parce qu'elle fait aucun doute
c'est une sorte de coup médiatique
un petit peu vain
et très très très malin donc on peut
imaginer que vladislav tkachiev avait
bien entendu cette position le matin
devant son échiquier la suite
et force est ici après petit rock quand
on a joué des 5 il faut jouer dépensé 4
puisque c'est nous mettre dans le plan
des cinglés finir par être en prise et
la cave est décédé cinq une petite
menace sur la dame on voit tout de suite
un problème stéphane c'est que la dame
était en train de défendre l'option ses
cadres donc le prochain coup double et
7,4 chef c'est jean françois kahn alors
à noter justement j'ai pensé tout à
l'heure si les noirs jouent le seul coup
qui continuent à protéger le cul ondam
c5 et bien les blancs gagnent encore du
temps il joue est sans doute le couffo à
trois avec plaisir à les grands grand
plaisir qui pose d'énormes problèmes
voit noir
à noter que la dame doit partir
maintenant qu'est-ce qui est le pion aux
sept îles sera prise aussi la dame doit
d'être enceinte et maintenant on joue
simplement si on prend ces quatre ici
qu'est ce que fait la mairie stéphane je
ne sais pas on est content les pièces
sorties et bien il y en a 4 pour les
blancs et 2 pour les noirs sachant que
la dame ici va encore devoir perdre du
temps grosse position avec un fou j'ai
deux énormes
cette constance largement savez tout le
débat de la partie toute façon et la
faiblesse de structures de sciences et 4
qui isolé de son autre pion l'on peut
même se demander une loi si le coup
cavaliers f3 tout simplement permettait
pas qu'à laisser cet arrêt que le guen
la qualité oui c'est également également
possible de regarder des matches comme
ça mais ici après qu'elle ait cédé cinq
coups d'avancé 5 n'est pas bon puisqu'il
permettrait aux blancs de sortir une
pièce en gagnant fait rire que les noirs
ont pas trop le choix il faut mettre la
case la dame sur une autre case est
alors si on la remet sur sa case de
départ c'est un peu un jeu de puissance
c'est pas très conquérant sefa très bon
qui rend donc il reste quasiment comme
seul coup à jouer et alors il reste deux
cases à la casse mais si c'est les 15-17
maxime a choisi la classe b 6 et arnaud
hauchard nous a confirmé que la caisse
dès cet été pour le moins peu plus
intéressante
c'est une case non naturelle c'est pour
ça que si le salut pourrait changer les
dames
peut-être on peut jouer simple voilà
l'idée de préparer à 6 chasser ce qu'il
a dit puis aux cinq chats c'est l'autre
cavalli ensuite échangé les dames et
jouer avec une meilleure structure de
pions parce qu'il faut voir que les
blancs vont jouer en france à quatre
dont il sortit avec un fiancé qui est
donc on peut regarder par israël et
structures isolées un pion voilà imagine
t on enfin vraiment un cas isolé mais
oui maintenant
maintenant on commence par à 6 on chasse
le kémalisme cela fait que le mail et
revient sur la c3s à d'autres et pas
trop intermédiaire oui et là et
maintenant plusieurs options soit que 5
cm salaire même très dangereux à cause
du fou g7 derrière l'aréna melançon
alors j'ai eu cinq états touchés sa
bouche le faux mails en revanche le coût
autour des 8 par exemple loyers très
fort et pas mal du tout d'habileté pour
voir mon adresse aux cavaliers on a le
fou qui va rejouer dès qu'on peut on
sans lequel est sûre la casse et 6 lits
si jamais en échange les dames et dont
on va s'apercevoir que vous c'est vite
va pouvoir sortir leur argent libre est
ici des noirs égalise assez facilement
donc peut-être d'un v6 après qu'ils
aient cédé 5 et qui est peut-être là un
coup apprécié ou premières petites
imprécisions de
de maxime de médecine j'en prends ses
cadres à 6 à 6 quand même à locon
nathalie faucher c'est ce qu'ils veulent
ils étaient toutefois au moins la taxe
aux cavaliers maintenant qu'elle ose
histoire est ici tondez vite ton est
vite mais la voix est d'accord donc là
quand même il ya il ya quand même une
pression sur le voile sur la colonne des
lois parce que lecavalier d4 et cloud et
oui tu sais lire que s'ils bougent
évidemment la dame est perdu voilà
comment protéger alors à noter que tours
des 8 mai n'est pas le plus précis
toujours d'après arnaud hauchard parce
que c'est lui qui a analysé les parties
de maxime qui connaît très bien ce genre
de trucs donc c'est son entraîneur il
n'entrait il entraîne maxime
alors oui alors parce qu'aux échecs
évidemment maxime joue mieux car nos
jeunes soient au classement vélo il a
presque 2100 alors que l'or noir est de
1500 mais en revanche
arnaud et arnaud arrive à faire
progresser maxime tout simplement parce
qu'il a travaillé avec l'ordinateur il
prépare les variantes
il a une grande connaissance générale
des échecs et puis c'est vous allez
avoir une coach même s'il est inférieur
mais il connaît les faiblesses de son
poulain il fallait faire travailler dans
la bonne direction alors que soi même on
n'a pas être du mal des fois avoir ses
propres faiblesses et surtout donc
arnaud hauchard n'est pas un compétiteur
il n'aime pas il aime pas joué ils
aiment paris prendre des risques il apte
à perdre un peu comme dustin hoffman en
fait j'ai aussi cherché à la française
c'est ça exactement
donc ici à l'aise dans le rôle
d'entraîneur d'après rne autour des 8
n'était pas le coup le plus précis il
on pouvait essayer calé g4 qui encourt
originale avec carla son geste qui
attaque qui a taclé des quatre ex adam
v6 après analyse donc poussé évidemment
il semblerait que cook est un échec et
ne posent encore toujours pas de profs
d'accord alentours des 8 pour débuter il
ya quand même plus fous 3-1 fou et rompt
alors le problème de fou et rend on se
dit qu'est ce qui se passe est loin sur
le coup de 7 5 qui a l'air de gagner de
cavalli puisque si lecavalier bouge et
bien la dame des landes perdues
oui tout à fait alors le coup et cinq
est tout à fait légitime maintenant
l'inconvénient de ce coup c'est que ça
le fou pairs en imposant facile à une
pièce effectivement ces spas laquelle je
ne sais pas quoi voilà deux possibilités
ici pour les blancs un boucher le
cavalier parce que même si on perd la
dame et bien on prendra la dame penny ou
de faire un petit costume ce qui serait
dame b 3 qui attaqueraient la dame
classards et traquer les deux ans mais
je pense que le meilleur coup ici dans
cette position on veut échanger les
pièces sont jour qui validait trois tout
simplement qui a et b 3 qui est en fait
la dame des six est aussi elle même
attaqués par leurs jouets 3
notons que si on fait
d'un prof ou combinaison qui pourrait
être tentante 20 prend berne pour
plusieurs raisons simplement qu on prend
dame déjà avec une qualité mais aussi on
peut jouer demain prend des mythes et
chaque intermédiaire oui y'a rien à
trouver dans sa nature et ses tours
prend dame évidemment on prend la dame
et c'est un simple chèque de 6 3 points
dames on vous prend dame voilà est ici
là c'est la vraie c'est la vraie
catastrophe maintenant parce qu'on voit
que les québécois va sauter sur la case
à 5 et à ta question 17 un peu plus du
fou on a plus de tours sur la huitième
en plus du fou donc ici les pièces marc
sont trop trop mal placé là on peut plus
s'en sortir trop d'activités pour les
membres parce qu'en fait c'est de là que
ça se joue la partie c'est sur
l'activité des pièces blanches très bien
donc tout le problème de maxime c'est
d'essayer d'annuler pour daniele cette
activité des pièces blanches pour
essayer au final de faire valoir ce
petit affaiblissement c4 mais c'est très
très dur donc eu six choisie par maxime
mais là la position va commencer à se
dégrader assez rapidement après le bon
coup de nice est avocate chez fmb 3
quand même donc même si la région c'est
qu'ils vont certainement jouer ce coup
là on est paré dame b3 alors avec l'idée
c'est que sur dame programme
on va reprendre soit du kavé 10,3 du fou
soit du cabinet soit du pion les deux
vont être très fort la b1 b6 exercer un
travail défensif trop important le
fourbe et de l'option b sat va être
faible toutes les cases sont faibles une
fa cup la dame quand le québec et y
revient c'est vraiment trop dur donc ici
il faut garder la dame c est ok
maintenant tout raté un mail à la
position blanche stéphane commence à
être vraiment très forte
ça se voit au niveau des pièces sorties
oui parce que lennon a toujours prôné
imaginant fou 17 pour sortir ce fou et
déjà qu'ils étaient très un ferme et
c'est sa seule caste de développement et
bien c'est pas possible puisque le pion
bessette et sur l'oeuf de la dame tout
simplement de la dame et du fou
voilà ça gagnerait un pion c'est la
partie et la partie puisque la position
devient écrasante
ça va être très difficile
de tenir simplement par exemple son tour
à sept ans jouer dame b 3 on vote
maintenant le tour aussi à des problèmes
de risques d'avoir des problèmes ne
verra ni fameux rayon x tu as fait si
trop trop difficile encore une fois
parce que c'est très difficile pour les
noirs de se développer c'est l'après
alors imaginons que les noirs parions
aussi se développe avec arles et b17 et
bien sous le coup de la partie voilà il
faut sentir ses pièces sinon on va se
faire écraser petit à petit les blancs
vont prendre de plus en plus des espaces
et on l aura de moins en moins de
poussines autre chose stéphane cecchi et
b17 s'inscrit dans un plan qui est de
mettre le québec dans ses 5 pour bloquer
ce option permettant gagnerait du temps
sur la dame avec à gré du temps sur la
table donc ça c'est un bon coup à priori
très logique donc ladislav logiquement
également empêche les d'arrêt lancé cinq
patrons sur calais c'est simple on voit
que ça imaginez on perd tout de suite
imaginons tonnes de matériel cavalli
valeur maintenant il y avait des pour
cammalleri dame prend forcément
maintenant qu'elle est comme si je suis
pour la cavale et prend aussi
s'attaquant à la fois la dame par le fou
et le cavalier va prendre la tour des
huit gagnants des troubles la dame est à
l'accueil par le fou c'est la plus
grosse menace donc il faut enlever la
dalle et la tour des huit est perdu est
également attaqué parce que c'est énorme
c'est énorme c'est une attaque à la
découverte on appelle ça c'est ça une
découverte donc ici après cavalia 4 il
n'est pas question de jouer kelly c5 la
position de maxime est très délicate
déjà puisqu'on voit plusieurs plans
possibles pour gwladys casquette chef on
voit sans doute la menace c5 qui va se
profiler c5 et c6 éventuellement donc on
voit quand même loi comme un bellier si
on veut que cette position du côté
gauche
c'est qu'il ya une domination sur les
cases noires pour les blancs de ce côté
là et sur les cases blanches et aussi
avec le fou donc il ya derrière yann
merveilleux de fouesnant
bien dans le spleen dans le style de la
nisa on le voit peut-être plus
spécifiquement sur les cases blanches
sur les cases noires pendant puisque les
pions les pions noirs blancs contre
toutes les cases et les pions les pions
noirs censure blanc donc voilà donc qui
contrôlent plus d'ailleurs la seule
pièce en dehors de la dame qui est la
plus puissante qui contrôle un peu des
cases moi c'est le cavalier 17
donc on se dit que ce plat dessert il
faudrait ne pas le bouger en fait oui
oui mais tout à fait donc maxime dans
cette fiction a choisi de jouer cavalier
gkp un coût qui d'apparence logique ils
essaient d'éliminer le fou mais bon
l'apparence logique puisqu'on je joue et
y avait les branches ont évidemment
éliminer cette belle pièce
on remarquera plus qu'à 1h26 servait pas
spécialement la grand chose pour le
moment ça libère aussi de l'action il
faut g7 mais c'est un peu un aveu
d'impuissance au cou kg 4 parce que ça
veut dire qu'il ne sait pas comment s'en
sortir de ce côté là très bien alors là
maintenant faut pas perdre de temps aux
échecs quand on est attaqué au général
faut répondre par une attaque ça c'est
beau aussi on peut si on peut nommer un
peu pour éviter que l'adversaire seront
groupés et puissent disposer ces pièces
ou g5 attaque la tour mais là la
position commence à devenir très très
délicates alors déjà on peut imaginer on
peut voir un couple sur une crête et
maureen énorme faute ce serait du golf 6
8 6 c'est pas possible on l'a dit
plusieurs fois dans des annales stéphane
voilà c'est l'avancée du puits aurait
fait toujours trop tôt proto est ici sa
soeur la fourchette confort qu fort
qu'un loyer très très forte elle même
attaque tout takkedine tour gagne toute
la maison donc m6 impossible une
alternative ça pour être trop vite mais
bon on comprend aisément que maxime
n'est pas venu jusqu'à la tour est plus
complètement passive dans l'est derrière
son pion elles contrôlent plus rien donc
on n'a pas envie on est écrasée serre
que là on va on va plus pouvoir sortir
on va étouffer tout simplement le coup
h3 on va chasser ce cavalier on va
revenir dans la position d'avant la tour
en des huit exercer qu'un un travail sur
le cavalier
là maintenant donc ici peu d'espoir de
survie
les pièces blanches sans trop fort tout
simplement fou j'ai cinq dans le doute
maxime s'est dit je vais essayer
d'échanger des pièces ce qui est un bon
raisonnement ça beau réflexe quand vous
arrivez pas trop à vous défendre et
essayer d'échanger des pièces dont qu'il
ait joué foulée 6 ou quand on sait pas
quoi faire échanger des bises quand on
sait pas quoi faire quand tu sais pas
quoi faire changer des pièces et dans la
très bonne solution fonds précise donc
là qu'avait dit des points et 6 alors ça
donc ça par rapport aux à la remarque on
a fait tout à l'heure semble petites
imprécisions de plus oui puisque on
enlève un contrôle supplémentaire sur
les cases noires donc puisque ce car les
17 contrôle encore un petit peu les
cases noires du côté gauche
oui le coup kg pour m6 et est
probablement préférable pour garder le
contrôle de m même si on voit bien que
les noirs restent extrêmement regrouper
ses resterait difficile pour eux mais
c'était peut-être moyen revenu enfin
plus précis ici bas le problème c'est
après le coup c'est 5 on bouge plus et
plus rien qui bouge
alors que se passe-t-il et sur ce coup
là domination totale si on joue comme
les princesses 5 et 4 ans et 5
eh bien on peut utiliser le clouage donc
il ya plusieurs possibilités pour
utiliser de l'hommage le plus adapté 100
m dames c3 voilà un cas il peut plus
bouger puisque la dame serait perdu
exactement aux dix autres choses aussi
on a un oeil sur le cavalier ici un tout
c'est important également
et si les noirs jouent eux cinq une
contre attaque alors des six est
impossible très important stéphane à
cause du sujet 2 qui prend la parole à
taux bas sur ça c'est pas bon donc ici
une contre attaque e5 ça a l'air d'être
un peu un coup d'épée dans l'eau il
suffit de bouger le cavalier on va me
reste équivalent you this way mais
sûrement va jouer cavalier 3 sans doute
alors qu'ils avaient des p3 et sur kevin
smith l'a dit tout simplement d'un grand
dam dam printemps puisque sur lequel
dépend le tour des huit nathan d'éviter
dans l'air voilà c'est ça bon donc déjà
qui lancera résidus qu'il faut prend
donc il a repris du cavadee à des
cavaliers maintenant d'un v6 coup très
fort donc là c'est du calcul c'est alors
ya beaucoup de calculs mais il ya
également un autre facteur stéphane qui
positionne lcd celui ci donc là
évidemment je l'espère et je fais tout
calculé jusqu'au bout de toute façon
parce que c'est pas très compliqué enfin
en tout cas pour lui c'est simple mais
ici le
stratégiquement il se passe que le
défenseur c'est la dame c'est cette wii
c'est la seule pièce qui tient encore la
caisse noire
si on échange cette pièce est bien
invasion du cavalier réveil du fou
éventuellement dès qu'il prend s'est
vite tomber cette qui tombe il y en a
deux il y en a de partout au canada
partout donc ici ils feignent enlève la
milesse lanceur voilà on en est la pièce
qui défend encore un peu la baraque
c'est ça qu'est ce qui se passe il est
noir par exemple près le pion c4 alors
dame français qu'après l'accord des huit
reprises la tour des mythes et en plus
malheureusement avec échec s'il n'y a
pas trop de choix le slalomeur tout seul
encore de d'échanger les dames alors
d'un programme il ya un autre problème
stéphane on va voir tout de suite ses
cavaliers prend tomber vite obligatoire
est ici j'étais en train de me dire ou
es ce qu'on allait mettre ce cavalier
il y avait plusieurs possibilités que
j'envisage et qui a laissé six mais
enfin quel est saisie celle de pas
marché donc simplement qu'il y avait
trois
l'idée c'est que là l'idée s'éclate on
n'a pas bougé et si on échange
il ya une invasion à la 8e ah oui là on
est en plein dedans on va on va envahir
ici impossible d'empêcher ce coût est de
vous évitera le flou civic sera perdue
point les pièces noires complètement
muselé c'est une cata cet énorme tour 17
à le seul coup on voit par exemple
défense de la dame où il peut pas il
peut même il peut pas échanger ni jouer
autre chose à faire et là ça se finit
assez mal après le coup c'est 5
il ya tout simplement plus de coups il
ya plus de couple donc là c'est
quasiment un besoin en fait va l'amener
à cesser 6 puis on prend 7 6
fou prend 6,6 et l'attaqué est une des
deux toilettes deux tours soit un prix
de mal à communiquer plus de défenses
tourbe est vite tombée 8 et belle
conclusion ici de quatre chefs avec
damas sept ans ferme la tour on est dans
la torpeur bien ravir quelle est la
menace
la menace est
alors y en a plusieurs mais je sais 6,6
et la mode à ce qui va faire très mal
calé b6 aussi va sûrement faire très mal
enfin il ya plus de coups il plus tout
simplement que de coûts proviendront qui
l'a étouffé en fait il est en fait
complètement vrai on voit que la cette
domination stratégique total de toutes
les pièces blanc va-t-il encore essayé
le singe qui permet un beau finish un
mot la combinaison final combien de
temps que vous la main voilà faites vous
la main les blancs jouent et gagnent les
blancs jouer conclut cette partie là
vous arrêtez votre émission et ses
filets sur pause appuyer sur pause et
vous essayez de trouver le bon coup est
ici le bon coup c'était bien entendu
cavaliers c6 étonnant puisque urbain
dans le cloud étant prise alors si on
prend un cavalier parvient c'est
obligatoire stéphanie apparaît en fait
ce qu'il faut voir c'est d'abord cherché
un autre couple prendre le cavalier la
tourbe ebit est attaqué on peut pas la
défendre comment le prend de la dame de
la dame
il ya fou prend dame tout face et ça
fait mal et après il y en avoir la tour
qui tombe en a perdu elle est là
toujours qu'un enfant est obligatoire
est ici petite conclusion tranquille
tourcoing 17 un superbe en attaque alors
on a éliminé le défenseur de la dame ce
qui veut dire que maintenant sur
cavaliers prend 17
la dame c7 est en crise voilà donc il
faut re voilà donc le seul coût qui
reste sur six ont fait d'un programme
eh bien on a perdu une tour sur des
programmes la fin alors qu'ils étaient
attaqués on a perdu on a perdu pied on a
perdu une pièce qu'elle était alitée
parions et s'est à son tour contre pièce
ça suffit maintenant pm dont dresse
toujours avec le prochain tour contre
pièce est à ce niveau là c'est mort
parce qu'il gardera gardien ya pape y en
a de plus c'est que dalle n ya rien et
la dernière petite variante stéphane
madame prend 17 peut-être à ouidah prend
17 d'appréhender 8 voilà c'est tout
simplement donc c'est la tour qui n'est
plus défendu et l'appareil n'a gagné
là on a une égalité aussi et toujours
que des six qui allait décider qui sera
perdue donc une très très belle partie
stéphane de vladislav tkachiev
il a sorti toutes les pièces au centre
il a bien joué il a bien dominé son
sujet donc une réalisation impeccable
comme d'habitude et maxime qui a pas
réussi à trouver des bonnes défenses
mais je crois qu'on a repris décidément
très fort ce set cette nouvelle émission
puisqu'on arrive au terme déjà donc ça
va très vite
finalement 52 minutes et je crois car on
a bien fait le tour de la rentrée alors
évident la prochaine émission c'est quoi
et bien c'est le top du top de cette
rentrée 2006 2007 c'est la réunification
du championnat du monde
attendu depuis 1993 le vainqueur de
kasparov en l'an 2000 vladimir kramnik
va enfin rencontrer un challenger il a
rencontré peter l'écho il ya deux ans
mais c'est vrai c'est un peu dallas mais
cette fois il va rencontrer le champion
du monde fidh et celui que tout le monde
attend vesselin topalov le numéro un
mondial de la liste ça va chauffer ça
c'est un très très beau match et bien on
va vous donner une preview dans la
prochaine émission et va voir avec
analyse des deux parties de chacun des
deux joueurs n'est pas dix jours deux
joueurs et on suivra les chanteurs nous
bien entendu bien sûr aux championnats
du monde sur les gones alors à très
bientôt se donne à tes livres merci de
nous avoir suivis merci nous est fidèle
inscrivez-vous sur la newsletter de
diagonale tv sur diagonale tv.com et
vous retrouverez toutes les news de
l'émission on a besoin de vous pour
continuer à exister parce que cydia
connaissances en téléspectateurs ça n'a
pas de sens où les d'accord j'ai entendu
voilà donc à très bientôt et je crois
qu'on peut envoyer le jeu
et